[Music]
well
the first thing i'm probably gonna do is
have
a sleepover like a huge sleepover with
all my friends
um
like some parties like a pool party or
something
ten-year-old maya huber is one of more
than two thousand american children
who've received two doses of the
biontech fisa vaccine initial findings
from a study of five to 11 year olds
show that the vaccination is effective
and safe
young children are already getting the
job in other countries too in cuba with
a home-grown serum as well as china and
cambodia where they're getting the
cylovac inoculation meanwhile in europe
the vaccination of teenagers is making
headway here two data from the us were
decisive they show that the benefits of
vaccination outweigh the risk of very
rare vaccine side effects
welcome to our cobit 19 special i'm
monica jones thanks for joining us now
covet 19 is primarily a respiratory
infection that attacks our lungs two
years into the pandemic we know that the
virus can also harm other organs
including our heart
getting vaccinated to protect yourself
and others should be the obvious answer
but now a study in the us claims that
the jab could be worse than the disease
at least for teenagers
for many teenagers getting vaccinated
against covid19 is a cause for
celebration
but one u.s study appears to suggest
teenage boys who have the fisa vaccine
have an increased risk of developing an
inflammation of the heart muscle
symptoms of myocarditis include a
stabbing pain or a tightness in the
chest
shortness of breath when walking and
resting and flu-like symptoms like a
high temperature tiredness and fatigue
it can also include heart palpitations
the study found that between january and
june this year
rates of adverse cardiac events for boys
aged 12 to 15 after their second dose of
advisor vaccine was just over
162 per million
this is nearly four times the number of
otherwise healthy unvaccinated teenagers
who'd be expected to end up in hospital
with covid19 over a similar time period
the incidence in the study works out as
16.2 cases of myocarditis per 100 000
people
that's pretty much bang on average for
the general population
and the paper has some limitations
the research hasn't yet been reviewed by
the scientific community
the number of people in the study at 257
is enough to be interesting but not
enough to be groundbreaking
covert itself can cause myocarditis too
the study of 240 000 people published in
the new england journal of medicine
found being infected with a coronavirus
was associated with 11 cases of the
condition per 100 000 people
that same paper found for all age ranges
being pfizer vaccinated was linked to
2.7 cases per 100 000 people
the link between vaccinating teenagers
and contracting myocarditis isn't
exactly clear
but with more data on the way following
the uk's recent move to offer covid
vaccines to 12 to 15 year olds it's
likely that will change in the coming
months
dr jacob arman is attending physician
and pediatric infectious disease and
critical care specialist at the
university children's hospital in
dresden he joins us now good to have you
with us uh i'd like to hear your opinion
what do you make of that u.s study
suggesting that teenage boys who have
the fisa vaccine have an increased risk
of developing an inflammation of the
heart muscle
well um
it shows that there's no medical
intervention intervention without any
risk and it also shows that the risks
depend on different factors gender and
aids being one of them so
having a risk profile for 20 to 40 year
old women doesn't mean that it's the
same for 12 to 15 year old boys so you
do need to get those numbers and you
need to weigh the risk and benefits for
each and every age group
and gender in this case
the data is actually not that surprising
there was a cdc update i think four to
six weeks ago that basically showed a
similar magnitude of
myocarditis after the second
dose of biotech pfizer
in adolescence the the difference in
this study now is that they focus on
primarily healthy kids so with the ctc
update you always got the number of
myocarditis compared to the icu
admissions and hospitalization but those
included the
adolescence of comorbidities as well and
so there's no real discussion that those
kids will benefit from the vaccine the
question is if a
family healthy kid will also benefit
from the vaccine but does it have
anything to do with the fact that it's
an mrna vaccine because the study only
looked at fisa vaccines
so we do see similar rates of
myocarditis with moderna which also is
an mrna vaccine so it seems that those
vaccines have a increased risk of
myocarditis given that the
other vaccines at least in the u.s and
europe are not approved for this age
group we don't really have data on the
side effects of asha seneca or johnson
johnson in this age group
now of course you just said it's also
about balancing the risk in the u.s we
hear the children now make up one in
five new covet cases there were some 30
000 kids hospitalized in august
and there were 10 times more
unvaccinated kids in hospital than
vaccinated ones
how to balance the risk of vaccine side
effects and a serious infection
so
again i think the number is not really
fear because not every kid had a chance
to be vaccinated so at this point um
especially in the age group up to 12
years of age you basically only have
unvaccinated kids so all those kids will
be unvaccinated if they go to the
hospital um but more importantly um
not every admission
from a child who is infected with south
korea too means that he's admitted due
to his infection so we internally we
have a national registry for all
hospitalized children and we see that
eighty percent of the children who are
admitted to the hospital and have a um
infectious thirst kobe two are not in
the hospital due to the infection they
are there for completely different
reasons and just happen to be infected
and i don't know the exact number in the
united states but it will be similar so
from the 30 000 kids who are admitted
only a small percentage is actually
admitted due to the infection and
therefore
you really have to say um even with
those numbers a primarily healthy kid
has a minimal risk of severe covet 19.
nevertheless pfizer this week said that
the vaccine is safe also for five to
eleven year olds uh that's an age group
that you're looking at at kindergartens
in particular would you advise parents
to get their little ones vaccinated now
so i mean we have to see the data so far
we only have the press release um but
regardless the the
study includes about 5000 kids 2500 got
the vaccine 2500 got the placebo what
this means is we can make assumptions on
risks that happen in roughly 1 in 2 500
kids the risk of severe disease in this
age is much much much lower so initially
i would not recommend a healthy 5ul to
get vaccinated if you have comorbidities
for example if this is kit has trisomy
21 yes should get vaccinated but if it's
a healthy kid i would wait until we have
more data until we until we have the
chance to see rare side effects like
myocarditis and then make
a call on
who benefits from the vaccine and who
does not that's a straightforward answer
there from dr jacob armand from the
university children's hospital in
dresden thank you so much
thanks for having me
and let's stay with vaccine side effects
a little longer because that's also one
of your questions let's ask derek
how do side effects caused by vaccines
differ from symptoms that occur when
naturally catching the disease
pretty much all of the vaccines being
administered in in various parts of the
world so far
are what they call reactogenic to a
greater or lesser extent now that
technical term
just means that they often cause
side effects usually mild ones like like
maybe some pain
or some swelling at the injection site
although sometimes they do provoke also
greater discomfort um
topping lists of other common side
effects that are regularly reported are
are fatigue
headache
fever
chills and and just generally feeling
kind of achy um some studies have shown
that up to two-thirds of all recipients
have one or more of those sorts of side
effects
soon after vaccination um they're more
common among women than they are among
men
and they also appear more often in
younger recipients than they do in the
elderly
more serious side effects like
anaphylactic shock
can also occur but they're extremely
rare
many of those side effects are similar
to symptoms that people report when they
catch covet 19. their
fever and chills are also common as is
fatigue and and aching joints and
headaches are also a regular occurrence
with covet 19. one young member of my
family
who caught the virus felt fine in most
ways but had a headache that persisted
for days
but there are also covet 19 symptoms
that are distinct from vaccine side
effects for instance
vaccines don't cause you to lose your
sense of smell or taste
and they don't cause respiratory issues
like coughing
it's also important to note here that
experts are reporting that the delta
variant
appears to often provoke more cold-like
symptoms that earlier variants of the
virus didn't like
a runny nose or or a sore throat
vaccines won't cause those either
but probably the most important
difference between vaccine side effects
and disease symptoms
is that vaccine side effects last at
most a day or two while symptoms caused
by covid19
continued to be felt by some
long covet patients for months
derek williams there well
congratulations to the trio who
developed the bionic fisa vaccine
biontech co-founders oslam tureche and
uber sahin as well as biochemist
cataline kariko who have been awarded
germany's top medical research prize the
paul ellis and ludwig darmstadter prize
and that's our show for today if you'd
like more information on any of our
stories you can find them on our website
dw.com
kovit we'll be back again tomorrow at
the same time hope to see you then
[Music]
you